hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead
today i'm going to explain a very
intriguing science fiction and thriller
movie called old
the story begins with a family composed
of prisca guy trent and maddox who are
going on a tropical holiday at a
paradise all island the island seems
perfect
the family is welcomed by the resort
manager and then they are offered
complimentary cocktails in the welcoming
party for the guests trent also meets
idlib one of the local boys who seems to
know something secret about the island
at night we discover that the family is
not in a very good condition
guy and prisca won a divorce making this
a last family vacation with their kids
on the other hand prisca unfortunately
also has been possessing a disease in
her body for years
in the morning while having breakfast
the family is approached by the resort
manager and is offered to visit a
secluded beach on the nature preserve
side of the island for a day where they
can avoid crowds
suddenly patricia a mid-aged woman
suddenly collapses and starts having a
seizure his boyfriend jaron is a nurse
and a guy charles who appears to be a
doctor immediately comes to help
the doctor and his family which consists
of crystal agnes and kara are also
invited and the group finally arrive at
the secluded beaches entrance and they
have to walk a little bit to reach the
place
upon arrival at the main attraction of
the beach we can see that it has a very
beautiful view but is surrounded by
steep stone wall which is quite
frightening
the group then meet a mysterious
traveler at the beach sedan who appears
to be a famous rapper while playing
around maddox and trent find rusted
knives and abandon toys but prisca tells
them to go away and ignore them tragic
strikes the group's vacation when a
drowned body is discovered the corpse
turns out to be sedan's missing
girlfriend after went swimming before
the group arrives the group is confused
by the incident and charles accuses
sedan of being the killer of his own
girlfriend
he is being accused because of his
non-stop nose bleeding a few moments
later jiren and patricia arrive at the
beach and the group explains the
situation to the couple the group
insists that they already want to get
back to the resort
when charles attempts to explore the
cave he suddenly feels dizzy and gets
knocked out indicating that they can't
get back to the path they used to enter
just now
after that charles's mom suddenly stops
breathing and dies with no reason
things become weirder as prisca
approaches charles and states that
something is wrong with her kids begging
him to check them
it turns out that trent maddox and kara
suddenly become significantly older
jumping about five years in a couple
hours
sedan tries to run away and is chased by
charles but as soon as they enter the
cave they immediately faint and get
thrown back to the beach
because of that the group now
understands that there is no way to flee
through the cave the doctor randomly
attacks sedan with a knife but magic
happens as the wound immediately heals
jiren suggests someone to swim against
the currents until they can find another
shore but no one agrees to the plans
nobody wants to risk their life
later the group conducts a meeting to
resolve the situation
patricia suspects that the kids are
reacting to viruses that's why they are
growing rapidly prisca and guy reveal to
the group that prisca is possessing a
benign tumor inside his belly
she explains that it is supposed to be
about three centimeters but jaron says
it's about a softball size
prisca suddenly faints and jaron
discovers that the tumor keeps growing
we now understand that the beach not
only affects their age but their
physical condition especially the
diseases will also grow faster
thus in order to save her life charles
will do the surgery the group remembers
that a wound will be instantly healed
after some time they manage to pull out
the tumor from her belly and prisca
manages to wake up
then sedan takes a look at her
girlfriend's corpse only to find out
that her body has totally decomposed in
just only three hours which usually
occurs in a very long time
jaren explains that hair and nails
aren't growing so fast because the beach
affects their cells and cells in hair
and nails are dead
sedan also reveals 60 minutes on that
beach is equivalent to two years old
thus everybody will age almost 50
minutes in one day
further tragedy occurs when trent and
kara are having fun together at the tent
which leads to cara rapidly giving birth
but unfortunately the baby has to die
because of the beaches rapid aging
effect the situation is getting more
tense when charles's worsening
schizophrenia causes him to kill sedan
brutally running out of time jaron says
that he was on the swim team and
desperately offers himself to swim
across the sea hoping to find help guy
then realizes that they were
intentionally chosen to go to the beach
because each of them has a similarity
which is that all of them have medical
records
later on while swimming maddox by
accident finds jaren's dead body
presumably dying because of drowning
on the other side kara hopelessly climbs
the huge stone wall hoping to find
answers at the other side of the wall
but she suddenly becomes unconscious and
falls to her death
the tragic event continues as patricia
suddenly suffers epilepsy causing her to
die instantly prisca and guy start to
suffer physical effects of the beach as
she struggles to hear voices from her
left ear and gas starts to lose his
sight crystal also dies because of
hypocalcemia amid the group struggling
to escape the beach maddox and trent
discover a notebook from the previous
traveler trent also manages to spot a
camera at the peak of the mountain
indicating that somebody is watching
them all the time
charles becomes completely crazy and
attacks prisca and guy but prisca
manages to pick up the rusted knife in
the previous scene and stabs charles
causing him to die because of tetanus
until now the remaining survivors are
prisca guy trent and maddox
as the night winds down an elderly guy
and prisca make amends before they
breathe their last breath
with only the now adult maddox and trent
in the next morning trent finally
realizes that there was a message sent
by idlib which he hasn't read
the message indicates that there is an
underwater coral passage
believing that the coral passage will
allow them to leave the beach without
losing consciousness they start to swim
through the coral
unfortunately maddox's dress gets stuck
at a coral and they struggle to escape
from water after they fail to emerge
from the water a resort employee
monitoring them reports that the entire
group has died
it is revealed that the resort is being
used by a research team from warren
warren pharmaceutical to conduct
clinical trials of new medical drugs who
have been using their guests with
medical conditions as unwitting test
subjects
since the beach naturally accelerates
aging of the guests the researchers have
been able to complete drugs lifetime
trials in just within a day
one of the researchers explains that
they recently just managed to prevent
epilepsy by giving medicine to patricia
during her arrival
patricia who suffered debilitating
seizures her whole life managed to avoid
an epilepsy seizure for about 8 hours
and 17 minutes at the beach or
equivalent for about 16 and a half years
in the real world after that incident
the manager starts to greet the new
group of guests but unexpectedly
interrupted by the arrival of trent and
maddox who eventually survived their
underwater swim using the notebook as
evidence of several guests gone missing
the pair are able to bring the police to
the resort once the researchers are
arrested trent and maddox head home to
live with their hand
the twist of this movie comes at the
very end when it's revealed the resort
is a front for the warren warren
pharmaceutical company the hotel manager
is the head of a team of researchers who
have been giving the guests with
physical medical diagnoses cocktails
that are actually experimental drugs
prisca charles patricia and sedan were
chosen specifically because of their
ailments on the beach the scientists
could monitor their health and see how
the drugs are working over time
the experiments themselves are
relatively recent however with a group
of people sent to the beach in the film
label trial 73
this indicates the 73rd time the tests
have been conducted and in the beach's
unique aging effect that's approximately
over two months
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching
you